N,ONE.ANG .M FREDRICKA ITNEWS I
ZELENSKIHO
E PLATFORM OA
POIBISBY
PEACE TALKS  VLADIMIR TIN.
A PORTInslatoIS ABTET AFRA OF O
SO ANY HEALT ANDPERSONWATIC USEN
ITARD, IT MAOP
SSSANDS.
S
F THOUSANDIONS O
VICTIMOF W
DON'T WANT T
T Y  SUBUSDECISIONO DENYHEC
WAT
PARTI  WE CONSTANTLYAKING OUTH
ATIO THE D THR WITH RUSSIANUR RO
THE UNITED STATES,
EVY T WHAT RUSSIA  WASTHESUKRAI
PEOPLING-U E, AND W IF WMA TTRU
THE PRESIDE ES AMBER TNDQUNO
ATTEMPTED MURDERS.
LET'S WAITHAVE THE RIGO AF
I DOHA TO BE SEPL
THAT THEY ARE ID OF HING.
THEY ARE AFRD R
CHILDREN.
E.
PEOPLEOPNGEI
AND RUSAM
HE TO BE ESN'T IT SEEMO
YOUR  PRESIU'VEK YOU.K FOURTH E
ESS OF PEACEL
IONS WITH RUSSIA, AND
THE SECRETY-S PLANNINGT MOALSO D
SENDING ARMS AND WEAPONS WEAPOUY
MOSCOW SATASKINDTRT  T?
MMENT?
REPEAT THGIOU? FROM THE VERYEG.
YO FOACEFUL IONS WITRU
KNU.N.
CRAR COM
KYIV AW
BOUT THE
NEEY THAT
THE R  AREEAN RYNG TPERMT REF W
ANLY
NS PROCESS
GERATO W CWE WIL
O MEWE HAVNE
T, ANPONOUGH  THEPPORT OF.
I HAD SEVERARSTI
RR FIRM SAYING THA BALANCEN UK
SUPPORT FROM THE
SECRY-SIDE ANDTHWA TAKING PLAC.
SOHAR THL,NDE RATHINK THATE HAOF
THE ESED RESPECTFUL ES F
UNDERS WHAT'
HETO HAVE  CTSECRETARY-GENERAG
CE HER
I ALWAYS ITOANCEF ST
MSHOULD UNDERS G  SPEAKIN ABOUT
E T
L TOUR
WEAPON DERY TN ABOUT UKRAINE L.
PONS
OF, WERE D INCE THEEG
.
ON, HOW E EELEAVINE TANKS.
WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THOSE ESYO
EXINARILY PRODUC PERENCEINPLAC
A Y,RSON CHOOSESONGLTING FKSPUA
DIACSO HS AL CHAGI
CHALLENGHIS MIND-SET
M,
DIPLY .
ICIF YOU LISTEN TO SOME OFQUEST
JOURNALISTS  TEY SEELY ERHAPS P
REPEUSRETHHIS DECO AHEAD AND UN
ZELENSKYAYINRE FOR TALKS I
SIGNIFICANT, EIA
RUSSIA HAS DONE, BURBS OF KYIV
E BRUTTHEALLY
-- AL ONR TALKS
MPENEDIL
THE UKIN
IN THOSEKSBEPOINT, AS THE IGSTEM
ATBING THE MOST RECE
SAS T'AL